hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game since all of you
enjoyed my previous video so much that
woody harrelson vs. garry kasparov game
we have another game work as part of
faces off against the celebrity at this
time it's talk show host comedian writer
David Letterman I'm sure all of you
heard about him and it's a game that
wasn't played like they sat down and
they play the game it was actually
played as since October 20th until
December 1st of 1989 so Kasparov as far
as I know was a was a guest at David
Letterman's late-night show twice once
in February of 1989 and once in October
of October 20th of 1989 and it was at at
that time that they played the first
move
so after the first move Garry Kasparov
left they continued to their show and
then they continued to play all the way
till December the 1st of 1989 over the
phone every every episode a David
Letterman would pick up a phone that he
would call Garry Kasparov and he would
ask him what do you play he played a
move and every time David Letterman said
something like hello kids
guess what time it is now and then he
said it's time for chess and then he
played a move or two depending on how
many how much time was attributed to
chess in each episode and I even
prepared okay let me just load it I do
have a photo of this although it's not
it's not a very high-resolution photo
let me just check ya here like I think I
have to make it smaller because it's
really of poor quality there's the two
of them Garry Kasparov and David
Letterman in in his TV show but I did
prepare even a short video footage
because I was extremely surprised and
impressed when I found out that there is
actually one and a half hour footage of
the entire show that Garry Kasparov
spent on David Letterman's late night
show it's available on YouTube and here
as the first move was for this is David
Letterman's the reaction took us power
of Z for so let's let's just check it
out
so here is a Letterman's reaction okay
so that was his reaction and Caspar z4
move and I will put a link to the entire
video it lasts about an hour and a half
so you can check it out if you have an
hour and a half to spend you know what
better time to spend it then to watch
Garry Kasparov in a David Letterman Show
so let's let's see if four and first
Letterman I responded with a five he
said okay you made a pawn move I'm gonna
make a pawn move but then he decided
distance and I'm not really something
you should go for and then he decided to
go for d5 so we have the Scandinavian on
the board we have he captures on b5
Queen captures on d5 and here Knight to
c3 by Kasparov Queen to e6 check and
here a David Letterman makes a little
joke he says it's only moved three and
you are already in check so Kasparov
responds Bishop to e2 and we have Queen
to g6 so moving the Queen already for
the third time a Letterman is now
attacking a spy respond on g2 but cuz
Perl of course is not is not very
impressed by this just second first he
played Knight to c6 my mistake it wasn't
Queen to g6 immediately Knight to c6
first and only after Kasparov played d4
then Queen to g6 was played now
attacking Kasparov's G to pawn and here
cuz part of a replied that Letterman
moves his Queen too much even though
Kasparov knows that the queen is
Letterman's favorite piece
so here Kasparov played Knight to f3 and
we have Queen captures on g2 already
moving the Queen for the fourth time
this game grabbing another pawn and
Kasparov says you will pay a very high
price for for moving your Queen so many
times and for grabbing those pawns
rock to g1 Queen to h3 the Queen has to
move we have d5 now forcing the knight
to move and here nice to a5 9 to a5
already this moon was played under on
November 10th so already already 21 days
have passed since the first move
so here David Letterman says the cast
part of that he can smell the aroma of
victory know that he can smell smell
victory and Kasparov replies that he has
his sense is the same aroma over over at
his place so nice to be 5na Kasparov is
threatening Knight captures on c7 to
fork the king and the rook and we have
Queen to d7 defending the c7 pawn bishop
to f4 now with a double attack and if
you're if you're hearing thunder and
maybe a little bit of wind that's
because there's currently like a huge
storm raging here in my hometown and as
I've heard in the entire Croatia here
Knight to f6 was played Knight to f6 but
there really is no way to defend c7 you
could play something like well not a six
definitely but you could go for instead
of Knight to f6 which was played you
could you could go for a five but even
then Knight captures you attack the
Queen and now after Queen e7 you simply
play Knight to c6 check and not to check
but attacking the Queen and after Knight
is captured now Knight captures on c7
the king is in check and after you move
the King now D captures and c6 opening
up a discovered check from the Queen the
King has nowhere to go you have to block
with the bishop and then first the
bishop falls then the rook falls it's
gonna be it's gonna be a quick end for
David Letterman
so instead after moving e5 he responds
with Knight to f6
Kasparov precedes Knight captures on c7
this is with check we have King to d8
and now comes Knight to e5 Kasparov says
I could grab your rook but instead of
grabbing your rockin e8 I want to grab
your queen
so Knight to e5 and he is in fact
correct there is really no good Square
for the Queen
in the game Letterman played my Queen
captures night on c7
he saw the variation that was coming but
at least he knew that he will grab both
of the Knights but it's no better to
not captured tonight if you play
something like Queen to f4 you know move
your queen away from any danger then
it's actually a forced checkmate
it's a four it's a checkmate in for a
forced checkmate so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the mate
in for I will give it a couple of
seconds as usual
so you're Gary Kasparov beat David
Letterman
to all of you who were successful
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in for this time and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is night captures on f7 we have
King 37 that's the only score available
for the King as this is covered by the
other night so after King to d7 the idea
is the Bishop to g4 check and now it
doesn't matter either you capture with
the night or East six all of this leads
to checkmate if Knight captures then
Queen captures East six and Queen
captures on e6 this will be checkmate
and if you don't capture the bishop if
you play east six then comes Bishop
Bishop captures the King has nowhere to
go except on e7 and after this you can
either checkmate by pushing the pawn
pawn to d6 or Bishop to d6 whichever you
prefer I prefer Bishop to d6 because
this will look much nicer on my
thumbnail and also I don't think this
this formation was ever created in a
game played by a world champion so in
the game after Knight to e5 attacking
the Queen Letterman did capture the
knight nightcap a queen captures on c7 a
knight captures on f7 would check we
have a king to e8 and now comes the
bishop captures on c7 so Kasparov did in
fact grab the Queen and Letterman
grabbed both of Kasparov's Knights o or
as he says in the game both of
Kasparov's horses we have Bishop
captures on a5 Bishop to f5 and Queen to
d4 now Bishop captures on c4 rock to c1
attacking the bishop and here there was
actually a really long conversation
before this rook to see one move but you
can check the entire conversation in the
link i will post below
there will be a link that will lead you
to the entire conversation that was put
together from the in newspapers articles
but you can also watch the YouTube video
that lasts like an an hour and a half so
you can you will not see the entire
conversation about this game because the
game lasted a really long time but one
user put it together and he uploaded the
article and chest comm so I will put the
link in the description below so you can
enjoy that as well
rope the c1 we have Bishop to e4 and the
now comes rook to c7 rook to the 8th and
here as part of pushes d6 so you can't
really capture it because simply Queen
captures the pawn is pinned at this
point cannot move because of the rook on
c7
here Letterman played b6 he attacked the
rook on at the bishop on a5 Bishop to c3
and here Bishop to b5 oh yeah that's
that's some loud thunder Queen to e5 by
Kasparov and here I mean there really
are no good moves for black after
Letterman played Bishop to e6 and here
again I urge you to pause the video and
find a beautiful checkmate in three I
really recommend you do so as you will
feel very good about yourself so I will
get a couple of seconds as usual so for
those of you who found the idea
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmate in three and for those of you
who just want to enjoy show here
Kasparov played Queen captures on f6
what do you do here well there are a
couple of ideas you can try out you can
go King to g8 King to g8 Queen captures
any sex will be checkmate on the spot
you can also go King here but then you
get rook captures on e7
there's no move the King can make a
bishop has to capture and now Queen
captures on e7 this will also be
checkmate but in the game Letterman
tried a different idea of course you
cannot capture with the e pawn deep on
is still pin from the rook Letterman try
it GE captures on f6 and now I'm sure
all of you can see it it's Bishop to h5
and this is now checkmate because the
rook is covering the entire G file the
bishop is slicing all the way here so
the King has nowhere to go
so yeah that's the game that's Kasparov
versus David Letterman I do hope you
enjoyed it
one another video in the series Kasparov
versus versus celebrities there are a
couple of other videos I know that as
part of did play a game against Arnold
Schwarzenegger but there are there's no
way to find you know the moves of that
game there are photos of the two of them
playing but it's it's impossible to find
the moves yeah but you know the Internet
is a big place if any of you have the
moves to this game feel free to share
and you know we'll show that again as
well and for those of you who are
interested in still dropping your vote
on my next series also the link to that
will be in the description below so feel
free to check it out and the vote for
the next series so yeah once again I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
we'll see perhaps we don't have a
suggestion or maybe with another
Kasparov versus a celebrity game thank
you